كم يجب ان نخصص من وقتنا لراحتنا البعض
يقفز
وعلى قسم من النوم لكن لم يتحقق الشعور
بالراحه ضغوط الحياه الحديثه يمكن ان تؤدي
الى انقاص الفتره المخصصه للراحه الكثيرون
لا يعرفون مقدار ما يحتاجون اليه من
الراحه بالتالي يدفعون الثمن متمثلا في
انخفاض الاداء وكذلك المرض
ونشره
من اليوم هو المقدار الذي يحتاج فيه المرء
الى الراحه اما الانشطه المختلفه فيجب ان
تنحصر في عشر ساعات فقط
كم مره نحن بنكون نمنا 8 اوقات تسع ساعات
كاميرا ممنوعت اليوم كمان بعضنا تعبانين
بالضبط بعدنا مرهقين مزاجنا نقول النوم
بجيب نوم النوم او من نحسب انه اليوم
اللي بينته شي كتير مهم لانه اليوم
متطلبات الحياه عم بتزيد كل ما الها عم
بتصير اكبر واعلى يمكن اجتماعيا ان كان
عاطفيا عمليا بالشغل بالبيت وهذا
متطلبات نشاطيه عندهم متطلبات اجتماعيه
عندهم متطلبات بالمدرسه النوم ما بكفي
تنقدر نستعيد الانرجي تبعنا
المتطلبات الموجوده نحن نعرف انه النوم
كتير مهم مش بس عدد الساعات المنامه بس
كمان الجدول اللي بنحترمه لانه عنا الساعه
البيولوجيه لازم لازم نحترمها نقدر نكون
في استمراريه بمستويات النشاط ما المقصود
بالراحه هل هي الراحه الجسديه ام الذهنيه
طيب الراحه الجسديه فيها تكون من النوم
بحياه تكون بالتمدد وحياه تكون بالمشي
البطيء بس الراحه كثير مهمه
يعني مثلا اليوم عم نحكي عن الراحه
الاجتماعيه وكل
المتطلبات الاجتماعيه والمتطلبات العاطفيه
كتير مربوطين ببعضها انا اليوم بثلا محل
ماني قادر اعطي اجتماعيا بقول ماني قادر
اعطي اجتماعيا
متطلبات حسيه ما بندركها خلينا ناخذ
العلقه بالعجقه منفكر احنا وقت مهدور بس
بهذا الوقت جسمنا حواسنا دائما على
كل شيء الراديو يلي ماشي الاصوات اذا في
اولاد بالسياره بتليفوني
كل هوالم متطلبات ذهنيه اكثر بكثير من
المتطلبات جسديه